Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Est-ce que vous savez combien
il y a de plantes sauvages en Suisse ?
Environ 3 000.
Environ trois mille plantes sauvages,
parmi lesquelles la moitié sont menacées.
Ces plantes sont
d’une très grande diversité.
Il y en a des rouges, des bleues,
des petites, des grandes.
Elles sont aussi très différentes
par rapport aux stratégies
qu’elles ont mises en place
pour se reproduire.
Car chez les plantes,
on a qu’une seule idée en tête :
se reproduire.
(Rires)
Chez la plante, tout est pensé
avec cet objectif.
Elle choisit sa couleur,
sa taille, sa forme,
le parfum qu’elle dégage,
la saison où elle va fleurir.
Tout est pensé pour optimiser
cette reproduction.
Bienvenue dans l'univers débridé
de la sexualité des plantes.
Contrairement à nous, les hommes,
et contrairement aux animaux,
les plantes ne peuvent pas se déplacer.
Comme elles sont immobiles,
elles subissent en quelque sorte
les conditions qui règnent
là où elles vivent.
Impossible pour elles de fuir
en cas de danger, de s’échapper
si elles se sentent menacées.
Ce qui est assez paradoxal,
c’est que, au fil de l’évolution,
elles ont malgré tout réussi à conquérir
tous les endroits de la Terre.
Elles se sont implantées partout grâce
à leur capacité d’adaptation,
leur formidable capacité d’adaptation
qui leur a permis de faire face
à la sécheresse, au gel,
à des températures extrêmes,
à tous ces éléments qui les entourent,
à d’autres espèces, aux organismes
avec qui elles doivent conjuguer.
Je crois que c’est Sartre qui disait :
« Les autres, c’est l’enfer. »
Pour les plantes, c’est pareil,
les autres, c’est aussi l’enfer.
Ces plantes ont fait preuve
d’une ingéniosité incroyable.
Hop !
C’est le cas de la pâquerette.
La pâquerette, c'est high tech.
Ça vous fait peut-être sourire,
mais je suis persuadée
qu’à la fin de cette présentation,
vous ne verrez plus jamais
cette petite fleur de la même manière.
C’est ce qui arrive parfois
lorsque je pars en balade
avec des gens dans la nature.
Je suis accompagnatrice en montagne.
Je suis fascinée
par les plantes et la nature
et je partage cette passion
en racontant des histoires,
en partageant ces secrets sur les plantes.
Je vous emmène en balade,
on va partir faire un petit tour.
Je vous propose une petite expérience
pour commencer.
Je vous invite à fermer les yeux,
et à lever votre main devant vous,
et avec votre doigt,
vous allez dessiner la forme d’une fleur,
la première fleur qui vous vient en tête.
Quand vous avez terminé,
vous pouvez redescendre votre bras.
Je vois que certaines personnes
ont encore le bras en haut, et…
Voilà.
Voilà la fleur
que la plupart d’entre vous a dessinée.
Un rond avec des pétales autour.
Est-ce qu’il y a des personnes
qui ont dessiné une tulipe ?
Ce n’est pas grave, vous pouvez rester.
(Rires)
Voici la fleur, le prototype de la fleur,
la fleur absolue,
celle qu’on va dessiner
quand on est enfant :
un rond, des pétales autour.
Si je vous demande d’associer
ce dessin à une plante,
à laquelle allez-vous penser ?
À quelle plante vous fait
penser cette forme ?
La pâquerette, la pâquerette.
C’est vrai, j’ai un peu triché,
j’ai intitulé ma présentation
« La Pâquerette, c’est high tech. »
Cette forme représente la pâquerette.
Cette petite fleur est très commune,
elle pousse partout.
Il suffit de sortir de chez soi, d’aller
dans le pré pour trouver des pâquerettes ;
en ville, le long d’une bande herbeuse,
ou alors en montagne sur un alpage,
on retrouve cette petite pâquerette.
Tout le monde la connaît et la reconnaît.
C’est la première fleur
qu’un enfant va offrir à sa maman.
Mais finalement que sait-on
de cette petite fleur ?
Que sait-on
de cette plante qui pousse partout,
dans le pré, en ville, à la montagne ?
De cette petite plante
dont on coupe la tête
avec nos tondeuses à gazon
et qui, quelques minutes plus tard,
resurgit
dans l’herbe verte ?
Pas grand-chose.
On va commencer par son nom.
Son nom, c’est Bellis perennis.
Bellis, elle est belle,
Perennis, elle est pérenne.
C'est une plante vivace.
Ça veut dire que chaque année,
elle repousse.
Ce qui est aussi assez génial
avec la pâquerette, c’est que
vous allez la voir en fleur
presque tous les mois de l’année.
On dit qu'elle fleurit de mars à décembre.
Cette année, j'en ai même vu
en janvier et février.
Voici une autre plante
que vous ne connaissez peut-être pas,
mais dont vous avez déjà entendu le nom.
C’est l’Arnica,
une cousine de la pâquerette.
Cette plante,
c’est comme un mot magique.
Elle soigne les bobos,
guérit les blessures, sèche les larmes.
Elle est belle, solaire.
Elle pousse en montagne,
il faut aller la chercher là-haut.
Or, on a une toute petite fleur
qui a les mêmes propriétés
que cette arnica.
Une toute petite fleur qui pousse
dans nos prés, tout près de chez nous,
au pied de nos maisons, sous nos fenêtres.
Une plante qui est disponible
toute l'année.
Une plante que tout le monde connaît
mais dont on ignore
complètement les vertus.
Cette plante, c’est…
J'imagine que très peu d'entre vous
savaient que l'arnica de la plaine,
l’arnica des prés avait ces propriétés,
que la petite pâquerette soigne
elle aussi les blessures, les hématomes.
Mieux, elle est excellente aussi,
elle a d’autres propriétés,
encore plus que l’arnica.
Elle va aussi soigner
notre visage, la peau,
c’est aussi la plante par excellence
qu’on recommande aux femmes
qui ont accouché.
Toutes ces vertus thérapeutiques
sont intéressantes.
On va maintenant parler du cœur du sujet.
J’ai intitulé ma présentation
« La pâquerette, c’est high tech. »
On va s’intéresser maintenant
à la technologie,
à la haute technologie de cette plante.
Je vais vous présenter trois parties
technologiques de la pâquerette.
La première, c'est l'effet baromètre
de cette plante.
Ensuite, on va regarder
de près son mécanisme,
comment elle fait pour s’ouvrir,
se refermer rapidement,
beaucoup plus rapidement
que d’autres plantes
et enfin, on s’intéressera à ses pétales.
Je vous le dis déjà,
ce ne sont pas des pétales.
L’effet baromètre de la pâquerette.
Elle est capable d’anticiper,
de prévoir la météo qu’il va faire.
Une petite astuce :
le matin, quand je pars en balade
et que la météo est incertaine,
je vais dans mon jardin,
je regarde les pâquerettes.
Si la pâquerette est bien ouverte,
il ne va pas pleuvoir, il va faire beau.
Parce qu’elle sait, dans les 2 ou
3 heures, le temps qu’il va faire.
Si elle est fermée, par contre,
il est certain qu’il va pleuvoir,
et hop, je mets un parapluie
dans mon sac à dos.
Essayez, vous serez surpris.
Comment fait la pâquerette ?
Pourquoi elle a cet effet baromètre ?
En fait, la pâquerette,
c’est une toute petite fleur
à côté d’autres plantes
qui sont beaucoup plus attractives,
beaucoup plus grandes.
La pâquerette, elle, elle a choisi
comme stratégie
de saisir toutes les opportunités
d’attirer les insectes
qui sont de passage.
Je vous l’ai dit,
les plantes ne pensent
qu’à une seule chose : se reproduire.
Comme elle est toute petite
et qu’elle sait le temps qu’il va faire,
dès qu’il va faire beau, elle s’ouvre.
Si un insecte passe,
elle a une chance d’être butinée.
L’insecte va se couvrir de pollen
et ira polliniser une autre pâquerette.
Dès que le temps se gâte, elle sait,
dans 2, 3 heures, il va pleuvoir,
hop, elle se referme pour protéger
son précieux pollen.
Les autres plantes en général,
s’ouvrent le matin, il fait beau,
elles se referment le soir.
Et s’il fait moche, elles ne prennent
même pas la peine de s’ouvrir.
Elles n’ont pas cette énergie
qu’a la pâquerette.
Mais comment fait-elle,
cette petite pâquerette ?
Qu’est-ce qui lui permet de s’ouvrir
si vite et de se refermer ?
En fait, elle utilise
un mécanisme hydraulique.
Elle va, si je prends une image,
ouvrir le robinet,
remplir de liquide ses cellules,
ses pétales, qui vont se rigidifier
et s’ouvrir, se tendre et s’ouvrir.
C’est comme si vous prenez l’image
d’une bombe à eau
qu’on remplit au robinet.
Ça se remplit, ça se tend
et hop ! l’inflorescence s’ouvre.
Lorsqu’elle veut se refermer,
la pâquerette retire ce liquide
cellulaire qui repart
et hop, elle se ferme, elle s’ouvre, elle
se ferme, elle s’ouvre, elle se ferme.
Maintenant on va parler
un petit peu des pétales.
Je vous l’ai déjà dit,
la pâquerette n’a pas de pétales.
Qu’est-ce qu’elle a alors ?
Cette couronne blanche autour,
qu’est-ce que c’est ?
Des fleurs.
What ? Des fleurs ?
Ça, c’est mes deux enfants
de dix et douze ans
qui manifestent leur étonnement.
Oui, ce sont des fleurs.
Prenez une pâquerette, détachez
une de ces languettes blanches
qui forment la couronne.
Avec une petite loupe,
vous allez observer à la base.
On voit ça sur le dessin à gauche.
Vous allez observer des petites
parties jaunes à la base de la languette.
Qu’est-ce que c’est ?
Ce sont les organes sexuels
de la plante, de la fleur, en fait.
Chaque pétale -
j’ose encore dire pétale,
mais ça sera bientôt terminé,
je ne pourrais plus -
chaque pétale est une fleur
à part entière,
a les organes sexuels pour se reproduire.
Idem au centre, les parties jaunes,
si vous les retirez,
vous retirez une fleur.
Les languettes blanches qui ressemblent
à des langues, c’est des fleurs ligulées,
et au centre en forme de tube,
ce sont des fleurs tubulées.
Une multitude de fleurs
composent la pâquerette.
Pourquoi cette petite plante a choisi
cette morphologie si particulière ?
Pourquoi a-t-elle choisi de réunir
toutes ces fleurs au sommet d’une tige ?
Vous imaginez ?
Ici, il y a une rose qui est grande,
belle, magnifique, qui sent très bon,
l’insecte qui passe
va tout de suite la repérer.
Si la pâquerette n’avait gardé
qu’une seule petite fleur ligulée,
qu’elle ne les avait pas réunies ensemble,
elle n’aurait aucune chance d’être vue.
Donc sa stratégie pour se reproduire,
pour attirer des insectes,
pour assurer sa descendance.
c’est de réunir toutes
ces fleurs au sommet,
au sommet d’une tige.
Maintenant que vous êtes initiés,
je vous fais Chevalier de la Pâquerette.
Désormais, vous n’aurez plus jamais
le droit de parler de pétale
en parlant de la pâquerette.
Je t’aime un peu, beaucoup, passionnément…
Vous ne direz pas « Je retire un pétale »,
Je retire… une fleur.
Vous vous souvenez de ce petit enfant
dont je parlais au début
qui offre une fleur,
une pâquerette à sa maman.
« Tiens, maman, je t’aime. »
Malgré cet amour inconditionnel,
c’est la onzième fois cette semaine
que ce petit garçon offre
une pâquerette à sa maman.
Elle prend la petite pâquerette.
« Merci mon chéri. »
Elle la dépose dans le verre
qui est sur la table
au milieu des dix autres pâquerettes
de la semaine.
Vous voyez l’image ?
Eh bien, aujourd'hui, tout est différent,
plus rien n'est la même chose.
La maman sait.
Elle sait que ce n'est pas une fleur
que son enfant lui offre,
mais un bouquet de fleurs.
Cette pâquerette fait partie
des 3000 plantes qu’on connaît en Suisse.
Parmi ces 3000 espèces,
je vous l’ai dit, la moitié était menacée.
La biodiversité aujourd’hui est
en grand danger en Suisse et ailleurs,
mais la biodiversité est en grand danger.
Les chiffres sont affolants.
Parmi ceux-ci, j’ai retenu
celui-ci :
environ 60% des insectes sont menacés
ou potentiellement menacés de disparition.
60%.
Vous imaginez ?
Qu’est-ce que va faire
notre petite pâquerette ?
Que va-t-elle devenir, elle qui a tout
mis en œuvre pour attirer les insectes ?
L'avenir le dira.
En attendant, je vais continuer
à parler de cette petite pâquerette,
de la trouver incroyable,
géniale, formidable.
Je vais continuer à partager
ma fascination pour les plantes,
pour la nature.
Je vais continuer à essayer d’aiguiser
le regard, de voir les choses autrement,
de chercher cet effet Waouh !
C’est quoi, cet effet Waouh ?
C’est cette personne qui s’inscrit
pour un week-end de découverte
à la montagne avec sa fille.
On a fait une pommade,
on a cueilli des plantes,
on a fait une pommade pour soigner les
bobos de la peau, on a mangé des orties.
Ensuite on a dormi
dans un chalet d’alpage.
On a -
On s’est levé très tôt le matin
pour aller voir le lever du soleil.
Des moments magiques.
À la fin de ces deux jours,
j’ai réuni les personnes en rang et puis,
j’ai mis en place ce que j’appelle
la pyramide des souvenirs.
Un tas de bois comme ça, en pyramide,
et chacun vient déposer une branche
et partager un souvenir,
un moment fort qu’il a vécu
durant ce week-end.
Le papa s’avance
et avec beaucoup d’émotion, dit :
« Moi, ça fait 40 ans que tous les matins,
je vais me promener dans la forêt.
Je croyais connaître la nature.
Eh bien, plus rien ne sera la même chose.
Vous avez changé ma manière de voir.
Mon regard désormais
sera complètement différent. »
Waouh !
C’est ça, l’effet Waouh !
Je ne sais pas
si vous avez eu l’effet Waouh,
mais en tout cas, je suis
persuadée d’une chose,
c’est que vous n’aurez plus jamais
le même regard
lorsque vous verrez
cette petite pâquerette.
Et peut-être que,
lorsque la prochaine fois,
vous croiserez une pâquerette,
vous repenserez à cette petite phrase :
« La pâquerette, c’est high tech. »
(Applaudissements)